here's a song for the good folks who we
pay to look for bars in each other's
boots I'm sure this line is long it's
longer than My Views but you're just
doing your job and what a job you're
doing
[Music]
embarrass our bad news now have you ever
caught here between us and our Dew
platinum's Golds and Silvers sing in the
Dell to the blues you see how far we've
gone together and yet she still refused
me to see to know how I want and just
forgot to choose
[Music]
look at us
foreign
[Music]
process
drops her off next to the childish man
of business
whose cares are fuel
enough to voice his problems with
toddler on fumes I heard her tell him
off like
who the hell are you
to assess this job
she could never do
just put your headphones on man
then away we
[Music]
got us trying instruments
got us trying
to move
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
very much
thank you
[Applause]